[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs michel guida
psychiatre expert judiciaire merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés alain penin
expert psychologue bonsoir à vous aussi
première question à la sphère sarah
limite donc soulevé de nombreuses
incompréhensions un changement de loi
est ce bien une demande sociétale selon
vous alain penin alors sais pas s'il ya
une demande sociétale sait qui est
certain c'est que cette affaire a
suscité une immense émotion a suscité de
l'incompréhension a suscité également
des réactions
et effectivement il importe de clarifier
de clarifier les choses de mon point de
vue effectivement vous êtes d'accord
mais celle qaïda il faut clarifier les
choses et surtout quelles sont les
choses qu'il faut clarifier pour que ce
type de décision n'arrive plus parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle a été très incomprise
et pourtant les juges n'ont fait
qu'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle est
écrite
certes les juges ont appliqué la loi
mais justement la cour de cassation dans
son arrêt du 14 avril a pointé une
certaines failles juridiques qui
existent à savoir le problème posé par
un en particulier les toxicomanes
malades et les toxicomanes délinquants
c'est là le problème c'est que la loi ne
précise pas très exactement les deux cas
de figure est certes il y avait des
habitudes de fonctionnement
c'est à dire que la plupart du temps les
toxicomanes qui n'étaient pas atteints
d'une maladie mentale existantes ou
indépendantes et les alcooliques de la
même façon et c'était plutôt une
circonstance aggravante quand il y avait
des faits délictueux ou criminel et
d'ailleurs
les toxicomanes en général sans qu'ils
arrivent un stade criminels sont
considérés comme des délinquants déjà
correctionnel de la consommation et de
la diffusion de la drogue
donc effectivement a fortiori quand il
était criminel et qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre pathologie sous jacente et était
considéré comme tout à fait responsable
en général ça se passait comme ça mais
dans l' affaire halimi évidemment qui a
connu un grand un grand intérêt
médiatique émotionnel évidemment là là
on a pointé la fatiha c'est que des
textes ne précise pas exactement ce qui
convient de faire donc comme la cour de
cassation jugeait en matière de droit
c'est pour voir si la forme juridique
est bien respectée elle a conclu dans un
sens ou en faisant un appel du pied au
gouvernement pour qu'il précise à
travers une loi ce qui compte c'est vrai
que ce qui retient l'attention dans
cette affaire c'est que le caractère
antisémite a été retenu non plus une
forme de voile à dact volontaires les
moqueries en plus que des moqueries même
après cette affaire c'est eh ben voilà
il suffit d'aller prendre des substances
voilà j'en ai même lu fumé un pétard et
elle est tuée qui on veut et on est
exonéré
c'est vrai que ça peut choquer est-ce
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut résumer
les choses selon vous c'est à dire que
il ya déjà si vous voulez une décision
au départ du juge d'instruction qui a
conclu dans un sens un haut niveau de
l'instruction elle même cette décision
du juge d'instruction a fait l'objet
d'un recours auprès d'un tribunal qui la
chambre en quelque sorte très bien que
la chambre de l'instruction qui est une
structure qui est chargée de contrôler
les décisions du juge d'instruction à
savoir s'il juge d'instruction conclu à
l'abolition du discernement
le sujet doit être généralement donc il
est interné en service psychiatrique sur
décision du préfet un des représentants
de l'état mais là donc la décision de du
juge d'instruction at t a été contestée
et la chambre de l'instruction qui donc
est une structure juridique qui existe
depuis je crois de mila enfin qui est
qui a rang acquis à cette affectation
supplémentaires parce qu'avant ça
s'appelait chambre de l'accusation et je
m'assurerai vue sur compétences élargies
donc structure qui fonctionne comme au
tribunal avec la présence de l'avocat de
la défense présence de la partie civile
et miss circuler qu'à vocal général deux
assesseurs un président est donc hissé
et les experts viennent notamment les
experts viennent présenter leur rapport
est
il ya des questions qui leur sont posées
et les avocats interviennent aussi et la
parole est donnée aux mis-en-cause aussi
en dernier lieu
donc ça fonctionne comme ce qui a choqué
aussi dans cette affaire c'est que au
final il n'y a pas eu de véritable
procès avant de vous faire réagir alain
penin je voudrais vous faire écouter
nathalie goulet sénatrice centriste de
l'orne sur sa proposition de loi
notre volonté n'est pas de juger les
fous comme on l'entend ici ou là nous
souhaitons seulement que dans certaines
circonstances la question de les
responsabilités puissent être tranchée
en toute transparence à l'issue d'un
procès
la tenue d'un procès est très importante
pour les familles c'est à l'issue de ce
procès que le tribunal où la cour se
prononcerait sur les responsabilités du
mis-en-cause alain penin votre avis
d'expert judiciaire sur cette question
experts psychologues les fous ne doivent
pas être punies satirique sophie aurait
dû ni tour
depuis toujours on ne juge pas les
malades mentaux on ne juge pas les gens
qui agissent sous l' empire une force
laquelle ils n'ont pu résister on ne
juge pas les gens qui commettent des
faits sous l'essai d'une pathologie
mentale d'un trouble psychique d'une à
la condition qu'il y ait une
imputabilité c'est-à-dire un lien très
étroit entre la pathologie mentale et le
trouble psychique par exemple une
hallucination par exemple un délire ou
un phénomène pathologique qui modifie la
perception de la réalité ce qui se passe
effectivement avec la prise de
substances psychoactives c'est que
indéniablement les substances
psychotropes entraîne des véritables
états pathologiques et comme le dit
fort justement michel gueïda il va
falloir faire la différence entre le
trouble pathologique est lui uniquement
par la substance par et le la
modification comportementale et la
modification psychique du de la
personnalité de l'homme qui est en
difficultés du malade mental qui utilise
en plus des substances psychoactives
donc en effet et c'est ce qui est
important c'est que c'est que l'ecstasy
4 ça ne concerne pas le psychologue mais
l'expert-psychiatre as à se déterminer
pour savoir si au moment de l'acte
le sujet était dans un état où son
discernement était soit abolie soit
altérée donnez moi il ya quelque chose
qui est quand même choquant pour le
commun des mortels ça veut dire que la
drogue on décide quand même de
l'apprendre et l'a clairement ce c'était
le cas c'était un jeune homme qui ne
semblait pas spécialement malades ou fou
dans sa ville tous les jours et ce jour
là il a décidé voilà de prendre de la
drogue donc on est un petit peu
responsable de son état tout de même à y
avait-il une intention criminelle au
moment de la prise du toxique
c'est la question qu'il faut que nous
nous posions c'est parce qu'en
pensent-ils chéri là mais évidemment la
chose que l'on peut dire c'est que la
prise de toxiques à ce niveau déjà et
fait souvent par des gens qui sont
personnellement en difficulté ça ne veut
pas dire qu'ils soient des malades
mentaux mais l'intention criminelle
existe-t-elle
au moment où le sujet prendre du toxique
c'est ça la véritable question en
revanche c'est vrai que l'effet du
produit est délétère sur la conscience
et sur l'organisation du comportement
lié à cette prise michel godart sur
cette question justement de volonté
ça enlève un finalement toute
responsabilité
individuel et le fait de ne pas être
responsable de soi même c'est à dire
qu'on peut on peut se les vides amant
dans cette affaire là comme je n'étais
pas à des experts et la réflexion a été
complexe puisqu'il ya eu je crois trois
collèges d'experts qui n'étaient pas
tous du même avis donc la détermination
de l'état psychiatrique du sujet avant
les faits façon dans la toxicomanie
s'étaient développés dans sa pratique
tout cela mériterait une étude
approfondie
donc il ya eu une décision de la chambre
de l'instruction qu'il a estimé qu'il
était responsable se dire au même titre
que toutes les personnes atteintes d'une
passion qui traverse donc à parce qu'ils
sont jaloux parce qu'ils sont
orgueilleux et cetera comme que
puissance il traverse une période de
folie en quelque sorte au dernier moment
et il pas question de déresponsabiliser
tous les états passionnel bien
évidemment or là aussi d'habitude
d'une façon générale et sans pouvoir
faire un ferrer exactement sur cette
affaire il était habituel que lors des
expertises effectivement quand il y
avait prise de toxiques ou d'alcool en
dehors de pathologies existantes de
façon sous jacente dans un contexte où
les tout le monde est supposé maintenant
connaître les effets très nocifs sur le
fonctionnement psychique des drogues et
de l'alcool s'est engagé la
responsabilité de par la pratique
c'était l'habitude que j'ai toujours
connu ça depuis quarante ans que je fais
des expertises et j'ai toujours vu sa
pratique est presque toujours comme ça
dans le cas présent je ne peux pas me
prononcer et je sais que dans la
commission de quitter commandé par mme
belloubet qui a été finalisée le 23
avril
par leur parle de la commune comme unité
de monsieur dupont moretti
les équipes qui étaient missionnés pour
étudier la réforme possible conclut et
qu'il ne fallait pas changer le
fondement des textes et qui convenait de
préciser en particulier le
fonctionnement de la chambre
d'accusation
en enrichissant et en précisant son rôle
précisé par ailleurs sur le plan de la
symptomatologie et des maladies mentales
mieux les choses concernés le malade
toxicomanes et le toxicomane délinquants
et puis veiller aussi à une amélioration
du statut de l'expert c'est je crois que
les experts ne s'en plaindront pas voilà
merci beaucoup je voulais vous laisser
venir votre femme merci en tout cas
alors qu'on apprend précisément que le
sénat vient d'adopter un projet de loi
concernant les responsabilités pénales
que l'on va découvrir donc ces
prochaines heures merci à vous